hey guys hope you are good Samuel leaves  here and on this week's video I'm gonna  give you a sneak preview of a  documentary that's coming live next week  now this documentary I've done it after  a lot of demand and it's gonna really  give you a real insight into my life and  also the life of what it's like to be  financially free so there's been a lot  of lessons is going to be a really  interesting documentary hope you guys  like it it's going to be live next week  and here is a sneak preview  [Music]  I want to make this documentary because  I've been on TV quite there and there's  always an agenda you know I can twist or  a spin and I wanted to show what real  life comes up like as a property  investor a lot of people ask me what's  your average day look like  so I guess here's the answer  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you